I heard we're just tired go out there go
but no way don't go out there wait go
out there but don't go out there it was
crazy like that and then they were like
okay we've got the dress rehearsal so
just go go out tell me
just a feeling we're gonna go to the
dress rehearsal yeah we have a technical
problem with their equipment and so we
can't transmit the lights right now but
we can do is go to their dress rehearsal
and I was right here for it and it's
just as good as what you would have seen
live tonight so check out the dress
rehearsal she really kept the show
together
Tyra did keep the show together it is
not easy you know because you know you
have a two-hour live show and the
prompter is for counted for the certain
amount of seconds right so but when
things go wrong everything that was
written on this prompter that you've
rehearsed before it's not the window and
you just got to be off-the-cuff and she
was just like okay people what's
happening right now a lot of things are
going wrong here now that you and Tara
are working together again what are you
gonna do to get her on Project Runway I
know that is a good I like that and I
know you do Germans Germany's Next
Topmodel oh and I've asked her so many
times to come she'll love Heidi she
comes to my dressing room before shows
and stuff she's like my girl but mom is
tired you're busy oh my gosh Oh Stu
saves I'm make sure they don't come bus
all right you gonna do that I love it
you